Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my joker 2 video.
We have a bunch of new footage
to break down a bunch of Easter eggs.
So if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Big reminder, this movie is going to be
elseworlds per James Gunn's new rules.
The way he treats the continuity,
there's the main DCU,
all the connected films
that he's talking about, like Superman,
Legacy, Batman, Brave in The Bold, Joker
2 with Joaquin Phenix in the Batman
movies with Robert Pattinson, Matt Reeves.
Those franchises will be completely
separate, doing their own thing as well.
A couple other things,
but for the most part, all the new stuff,
starting with Blue Beetle,
I think it sounds like blue Beetle will be
included in the new DCU will be part
of that new connected universe,
but there's a whole bunch of new footage
and reveals for Joker 2 just starting
with one of the biggest things
pricing Lady Gaga
in her full Harley Quinn makeup in suit.
Now this is obviously meant
to be a slightly different version
than the version in the comics
or in the previous movies,
in the same way that Arthur Fleck's
version of The Joker was a little bit
different from previous versions
in comic book
versions, like The Joker
never wore a suit like this.
But remember,
the movie takes place in the eighties,
so the whole style of the clothing,
everyone wears everything.
The whole vibe
is meant to be very eighties.
So her Harley Quinn costume is meant
to be a version like when we saw Margot,
Robbie's version briefly
wearing a version of the original version
of the costume from Batman,
the animated series in the comics.
Remember Harley Quinn started on Batman,
the animated series,
Then she came to the comics.
This is meant to be Lady Gaga's eighties
version of that, basically.
But all the pictures
here are from the same scene.
It's on the courthouse steps
and you see this larger
crowd scene with the police around her
and she's sort of railing against them.
The protesters are all protesting
in favor of Joker
with a bunch of signs saying free
joker, justice for Joker, Joker, marry me.
No justice, not guilty, not joking.
So it sounds like a continuation of what
we saw in the end of the first movie
where the mob starts to worship him
as this cult like figure.
And by the events of this movie
a couple of years later,
that's only gotten even stronger.
The crowd has grown even crazier.
The whole title of the movie
is a French term for shared Madness.
So the whole idea is that it references
Harley Quinn sharing in Joker's madness,
but also the whole grander idea of the
giant mob here sharing in Joker's Madness.
I'm guessing this takes place
much later in the film
after she has become Harley Quinn
because she starts out as Dr.
Harley Quinn.
So his doctor treating him and slowly
it turns into a Florence Nightingale thing
where she eventually falls in
love with him and helps him escape,
which is the second big scene
You literally see the outside of Arkham
Asylum burning to the ground.
So that seems like when they make
their escape, like they destroy Arkham,
everything goes crazy
and they use the chaos to escape it.
It looks like
this is meant to be a parallel
to the giant riots that you saw
at the end of the first movie.
And within these signs, there's
another huge Easter egg big reveal,
another big Batman character
from the canon is Harvey Dent.
So a version of Harvey Dent,
Two-Face is in the movie.
And remember,
he starts out as the district attorney
before he turns into Two-Face.
So it sounds like he's prosecuting Arthur
Fleck at some point during the movie.
And that's why the mob is protesting
at the courthouse steps with Harley Quinn.
It'll be interesting to see
if he becomes Two-Face during this movie
or if they just tease that
if they're really setting up Two-Face
during this movie, if they actually did
a third movie, he might wind up being
the villain of that third movie
like Joker versus Two-Face.
But based on Easter eggs around the set,
they say that it's 1983
during the events of Joker 2,
meaning only about two years have gone by.
He's only been in Arkham Asylum
for about two years.
When he breaks out or he is broken out
because in these brand new scenes
you actually see three different jokers,
which will remind
fans of the Batman comics
of the three Joker storyline.
But what I actually think is going on here
is you see three different Joker,
including Joaquin
Phoenix's Arthur Fleck in his Joker
makeup running through the streets.
But it looks like Arthur is running
from the other two jokers.
Right?
You see
Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur Fleck
character dressed in the gray suit
with the clown makeup still on, running
from the other two jokers,
one of them dressed like a regular rioter,
like in the regular street clothes
with the clown mass
from the end of the first movie,
and the other one dressed in his iconic
red suit with the same look that he had
at the end of the first movie.
He runs through the streets.
There are a couple of cop cars
that he runs past.
The other one rider with the clown
mask getting tripped up
and falling in the street.
There's a couple of different theories
about what's
actually happening in this scene
and what's going on
with these other jokers.
The most likely scenario is that
these are two copycats that are trying
to help Arthur Fleck escape,
and he's running from the police.
That's why they're police in the middle
of the street with the parked cars.
The whole concept of there
being copycats was a big thing.
After the first movie,
everybody had theories
that there would be a copycat joker,
or at least one during the events of Joker
to his whole execution of Murray.
The big call to action speech of his
was fully televised for everyone to see,
making him a celebrity in their eyes,
inspiring more copycats.
And there were a bunch of people already
wearing copycat clown masks to begin with.
It's possible
that you have a bunch of copycats
here dressed as the different versions
of these characters,
like as regular rioters with the clown
mask, others dressed
just like Arthur Fleck
to help him disguise himself.
And that's
why he's got the clown makeup back on.
And part of his followers here are people
who idolize him, are trying to help him
escape.
The other big thing you may have seen
in these scenes they're filming
is that on the marquee here,
he runs underneath
there's the movie Bucket of Blood,
which is a Roger Corman 1950s movie
about someone who's down on their luck,
who accidentally kills the cat.
Then people view this
killing as his act of high art
and start to praise him,
and he starts to seek higher
and higher levels of praise,
doing crazier and crazier things.
So it seems like they're implying that
that's kind of what's happening
during the movie.
Like Arthur Fleck gets praised
for his acts during the first movie.
People worship him and he starts to do
crazier and crazier things,
as do the mob of his followers.
It's also possible
that he's running from them too,
because the whole idea is that Arthur
doesn't do a good job of distinguishing
between what's really happening
and what he's imagining.
You can let me know in the comments
what you think
is going on in this particular scene
with these other jokers
either chasing him or trying to help him
run away from the police.
But we do know that Harley Quinn
is going to be in the movie
played by Lady Gaga,
and she will be a real character.
Like she won't just be completely imagined
by Arthur Fleck's Joker character,
but you may have seen in your feeds.
Todd Phillips
also celebrated Valentine's Day
by posting the first look at Harley Quinn,
meaning Joker.
And he's actually in his classic clown
makeup.
His caption
just read Happy Valentine's Day.
And in the scene, you can see Harley
Quinn is just captivated with Joker
like she can't believe what's going on.
She's so excited.
She's just so taken with it all.
She seems hypnotized by him,
which is kind of their dynamic
in the comics and in a lot of the movies.
Obviously in the DCU since that Birds of
Prey movie, they move slightly past it.
Like Margot.
Robbie's Harley Quinn
isn't enraptured with the Joker
as she once was in their relationship in
the comics goes back and forth like it's
meant to be the worst, most toxic
relationship you could possibly imagine.
They even covered that arc on Batman,
the animated series, with her
leaving the Joker for a little while
and just going to have fun with Poison
Ivy and briefly
trying to turn good in the picture.
It looks like she's just kissed him
like she's kissed him
because he's kind of flabbergasted
by it, like, hey, this is pretty cool.
And she's got his clown
makeup smudged on her lips,
which is usually the opposite way
these things go.
Usually it's the girl
who smudges her makeup on the dude.
But because we're talking
about the Joker here
who wears clown makeup, he wears
way more makeup than Harley Quinn,
even though she eventually does
wear a version of that makeup, too.
But you do notice they are both in plain
clothes, which means she may have
already helped him escape Arkham Asylum,
allowing them to actually change clothes.
And for him to actually be able
to put the makeup back on,
which could be leading
to this later scene, which we just got
the new footage of with her in actual
Harley Quinn makeup in there
spin on the original Harley Quinn suit.
They're going to be filming the movie
for a while.
So if we get more footage,
more cool scenes
and Easter eggs,
of course I'll do videos for it.
If you have any questions about
what's going on with the Joker franchise
or the other DC movies,
just write them in the comments below.
Everyone click here for that.
Brand new Zack Snyder Dark Side Returns
trailer and click here for my brand
new Flash movie trailer.
Thank you so much for watching, everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.
I.